all right do you have any questions
about your right to remain silent or to
testify on your own behalf
not at this time i don't all right does
anyone uh
promise anything or threatened you in
any way to keep you from testifying
no promises or threats your honor do you
feel that your decision not to testify
is a voluntary one on your behalf
yes it is now in addition to that i'm
convinced uh then that this is your
personal decision
uh and that you're aware of your rights
but there is a jury instruction
that may be read to the jury this again
is the one that you
get to weigh in on it's not for your
lawyer to make the decision again he can
give you advice
and i don't you don't want to know what
the advice is but you can
accept the advice or reject the advice
as to whether or not to give this
instruction if you would like i can read
this instruction to the jury
it's titled defendants right not to
testify the state must convince you by
evidence beyond a reasonable doubt
that the defendant is guilty of the
crime charged the defendant has no
obligation to pro
to prove innocence the defendant has the
right not to testify
this right is guaranteed by the federal
and state constitutions
you should not draw any inference from
the fact that the defendant has not
testified in this case do you understand
that instruction
yes your honor would you like that read
to the jury yes your honor
have you had enough time to talk to mr
nelson about whether that's a good idea
or not
i have your honor all right and so i
will read that to the jury on your
request
thank you all right anything else
regarding the defense case before we
proceed to talk about rebuttal
all right uh we'll have you rest in
front of the jury then
and we can actually take the microphone
back ms boss thank you
thank you uh
we'll have you rest in front of the jury
mr nelson
with regard to the state's rebuttal uh
it's my understanding that the state is
going to call
uh a rebuttal witness is that correct
okay um whoever's going to speak to this
if we can kind of outline
the topics and if you wanted to address
formally
uh the decision regarding this newly
discovered evidence
sure
um
mr blackwell
good morning honor good morning council
uh i was told in chambers that there was
some newly discovered evidence that the
state wish to present in a rebuttal
regarding
carbon monoxide testing would you uh
tell me what that was
yes your honor we have blood gas
evidence from hennepin county
that would have would contain blood gas
readings for the carbon monoxide content
in mr floyd's uh blood on may 25th
2020. all right and when was it
discovered how was it discovered
why was it not disclosed earlier it was
uh
discovered yesterday by uh dr baker
and what uh had precipitated in your
honor
was a piece of new evidence
it was a disclosure that came from the
stand during the testimony of dr fowler
that i want to show you honor exactly
what it was it was in one of the slides
that you owner can
see here if i adjust the camera
and what i'm referring to uh judge is
this very last
reading here on the bottom
uh where from the stand and the slide
that mr nelson prepared
was the statement and the discussion
that in seven minutes mr floyd's carboxy
hemoglobin
could have increased by 10 to 18
now that was a new opinion the word
carboxy hemoglobin does not appear in
the 31 pages of dr fowler's report at
all nor a discussion
about the carboxy hemoglobin content in
his blood
now the word the concept of carbon
monoxide
was raised in the report but not blood
gas issues related to
it was sort of uh discussed in the same
context
of uh sort of taking uh drugs uh through
uh the rectum and other things that were
raised generally but not
a specific reference to the
carboxyhemoglobin content
and mr floyd's uh blood uh dr baker
heard the testimony um had not himself
ever requested this noah had the er
physicians they explained that
when somebody's brought in and
blood gases are taken there's a panel of
them that are taken
uh the ones that uh get generated in the
records would be the ones that the er
physicians actually request
nobody requested carbon monoxide
readings
because they didn't see how that was uh
relevant frankly and and no one had
until this testimony yesterday
that was specific to the carboxy
hemoglobin content of the blood and set
it at 10 to 18
now judge cahill what everybody uh did
have access to
would be the flip side of the equation
uh
there was information on the arterial
blood gas content that showed the oxygen
saturation
content in mr floyd's blood and the
oxygen saturation was at 98
which meant necessarily to the extent
there was any carbon monoxide
in the blood it would be at most 2
this was the takeaway that dr tobin had
yesterday
from this new disclosure and that and we
disclosed that to council that that
would be something that dr tobin
could address based on information that
everybody did have available
dr baker simply then addressed the flip
side of it
was there a reading or measurement
specifically on the carbon monoxide in
light of this testimony from dr fowler
from the stand yesterday
on the carboxy hemoglobin content and
the slide which mr nelson introduced
let me clarify one thing when was the
test actually
run it it was run the the night of uh
may 25th uh when uh when george floyd
was brought in
and you did subpoena all the records of
hennepin county medical we did subpoena
all the records
and what they provided to you did not
have that in it
that's right trump did dr baker
spontaneously call you to tell you that
there might be something deep within the
computer records
that's not disclosed or did you seek him
out and ask him for his
we did not seek him out and ask anything
uh he had heard the testimony
um and uh thought that this record might
exist
um because he thought that well he's
aware that there's a panel of the of the
the tests that are run by the machine
and and then those that would go to the
er physicians would be the ones that
they request to see the values on
so and but we did not contact him it was
all the way around
and we're talking about carboxy
hemoglobin readings
is there also anything is part of that
specifically about
carbon monoxide concentrations yeah the
the
the carboxy hemoglobin reading
would show the carbon monoxide
concentrations uh your honor and
uh the record unfortunately mine has my
markings on it but it would return a
value for the carbon monoxide content
and then it would show whether or not
that result is in the normal range or
not
and that would be the reading in the
readout from
from the test results all right and
so specifically say carbon monoxide well
it gives the uh
the letter symbols for it uh
so it would um if there's a clean copy
what specifically does it say
maybe you could just read it off the
record it says specifically
in the oximetry values it says
f c o and then h
lowercase d 1.5
and then it gives the normal range of
zero to
2.0 percent as the normal range
it indicates on the record also
a name for mr floyd for this record it
would be
last name bronze and first name
tennessee because at the time
the tests were run they didn't know that
it was george floyd
i know on dr fowler's report that was
disclosed to the state
in february that on page 15 at the top
it says
uh if there's a defect in the vehicle
this gas
will be present or if a person is close
to the exhaust for completeness
mr floyd's blood co level should be
tested
so the state received that part of dr
fowler's report back in february is that
correct that's correct
all right uh anything else mr blackwell
before i turn to mr nelson yeah i don't
know nothing for all right mr nelson
mr nelson thank you judge um yes for the
record in terms of uh
rebuttal a couple of things i would like
to address first is this new
information that was just received i
would for the record indicate that i
received these test results at 7
53 this morning my as i understand it dr
fowler is on an airplane um and having
some difficulty reaching him at this
particular moment
i have spoken with other people from the
forensics panel they are looking into
these things
uh nevertheless your honor the point of
this
is is that this issue was specifically
raised as the court points out back on
february 22nd
some 20 some odd days in the or
40 some 60 days i don't even know how
long it's been i'm a little
a little uh time deprived at this point
the point being is is that the state has
had more than sufficient notice
dr fowler is opining that this could
have played a role
in his report he says and suggests that
for
completeness it should have been tested
or should be tested
the state retained and continues to
retain
any blood samples they are not within
the control of the defense
the state has had ample opportunity
to uh rebut any suggestion
as far as the um
as far as the information relevant to
the
mr blackwell references in terms of the
oxygen levels the 98 oxygen levels
what dr fowler testified to yesterday
was how
you can't rely on the oxygen levels
because it's
the carbon monoxide binds to the oxygen
and it can give a false reading you need
this hyboxy
testing the hyboxy oxygen testing
so the uh the bottom line is is that
this
is information that has been within the
state's control
the state has had ample notice that this
could have played
a part of dr fowler's testimony
it is incredibly prejudicial to the
defense at this point now
after dr fowler has testified and left
the state
to to bring forth evidence
again the jury being the trier of the
fact dr fowler was pretty clear he
was not saying that this was the cause
of death he's simply opining that
it wasn't considered by the state and
apparently it was considered to be
a ridiculous concept by the state of
minnesota
that didn't they didn't think to test it
since this trial has started in addition
to
this new and for this new evidence the
state has had multiple conversations
with a city employee
about the vehicle itself they've gone
and taken pictures of the vehicle
again all of this they've had pl ample
opportunity to do but this is what
they're doing in the middle of trial
even though they've known for a long
time that this was an issue
i do have i did receive also last
evening
a summary of dr tobin's anticipated
uh rebuttal points um that i
three of the four points i do not and i
do not see as
proper rebuttal but we can address that
later
well uh let's address that now as long
and then i'll
ask the state to respond to something
other than your
carbon monoxide issue yep so
last night i received a one-page uh
a one-page memorandum uh
referencing a conference that they had
with dr tobin it's baitstamp50417
they identify four areas of potential
rebuttal the first being that dr tobin
will testify regarding the significance
of the hypoxic changes from a physio
physiology and clinical standpoint
including his conclusion that the anoxic
seizure is not
indicative of a primary cardiac event
based on the timeline of significant
events
i believe that dr tobin has already
extensively testified as to the his
opinion of the significance
of the um anoxic seizure i mean that was
that formed a large basis of his
testimony and how he concluded
that now the fact that there is a
differing opinion that it's a cardiac
event instead of a
hypoxic event is
that's the nature again status had ample
notice it's not rebutting
it's just simply reintroducing what dr
tobin has already testified to
extensively well
my recollection of dr fowler's testimony
is that
he agreed that it's a hypoxic reaction
uh
but it's just the mechanism i think
we're talking about the mechanism was it
due to positional asphyxia versus
correct versus uh cardiac arrhythmia but
i think
they all agreed that it was a myoclonic
seizure as a reaction to hypoxia
agreed your honor but the the mechanism
being the point of what dr
tobin has already extensively testified
to right
right and the fact that dr fowler had a
different opinion
this is not proper rebuttal because it's
already been testified to
at least the what the mechanism of the
seizure was
has already been uh opined by dr
uh tobin okay the second area um
that dr tobin has indicated is he said
dr tobin will testify regarding the
scientific research supportive
of his analysis that showed how the
hypopharynx can be narrowed
again i believe that he has already
extensively testified to
uh his position as to the narrowing of
the hypopharynx
whatever this additional research is i
have been provided with a single journal
article
relevant to the treatment of covid
patients
that was provided to me last night as
well
if it's limited to that single article i
guess that could be construed to be
additional evidence but again dr tobin
extensively testified as to his
view of the narrowing of the hypopharynx
the third area is what is written
as follows dr tobin has reviewed and
will testify
as to his analysis of the two studies of
doctor
that dr fowler cited regarding outdoor
exposure to carbon monoxide
dr fowler testified that mr floyd could
have had a level of 10 to 18
carboxy hemoglobin as reflected in the
slides disclosed on 413
and that in his opinion this level could
have contributed to mr floyd's cardiac
induced death
dr tobin will rebut this analysis and
provide his opinion that based on
lab tests done at the emergency
department
dr fowler's analysis does not hold
so this email being sent at
4 53 pm last night or
approximately 5 o'clock last night
suggests that dr
tobin may have seen these test results
or
the test results done at the emergency
there's no indication is it
these new test results or is it some
other test result
nevertheless um nevertheless
it's our position that these new test
results should not go in front of the
jury first and foremost
and second if they were i would be
moving for a mistruck
based on this because again the state
has had ample notice
finally your honor the fourth the fourth
paragraph reads in his report regarding
the size of mr floyd's heart
dr fowler cited two studies the molina
and demaio
study and the northwestern study from
2021
however dr fowler did not cite the mayo
study that he referenced in direct
examination and he did not offer the
opinion
that mr floyd had an enlarged heart dr
tobin will clarify the facts underlying
these studies and their
application to mr floyd again
this is the very nature of our system
right there's an opinion and there's a
counter opinion that we
both dr tobin has already cited this
study he has talked about this study
he has talked about he acknowledged the
existence of the other studies
uh so these this is not
proper rebuttal because it's it's simply
it's already been testified to they're
trying to recreate and
read and get dr tobin in front of the
jury again
to talk about things he's already talked
about
the co2 fair enough right to some
limited extent
based upon you know dr fowler's
testimony
uh mr blackwell let's talk about those
other
aside from the lab tests those four
points that the state is seeking
to present rebuttal
obviously honor we wouldn't uh be having
any of these discussions this morning
uh had there not been new opinions from
dr fowler raised from the stand
and uh one of those new opinions uh and
one which i think i was objecting to at
the time
was his discussion of the mayo study
uh this had to do with the whole issue
of the enlarged heart the uh the
cardiomegaly
and he had disclosed to us his uh
reliance
on molina and uh the mayo
and also the northwestern study that was
in this report
and adriana well knows the whole point
of having reports and disclosures for
both sides
is so both sides have noticed for what's
going to be testified to understand
so he testified about the mayo study
anyway uh he expressed his opinions
about the mayo study
it was a free kick at the goal because
we didn't know that he was going there
what study again could you spell that
one because i'm mixing up demaio and
yeah
yeah the the myo study is m-a-y-o it
it's as though it should be pronounced
male 1
and and what
dr tobin would would talk about uh would
would be
uh that particular study uh and the fact
that
in the opinions that uh dr
fowler had presented in his report he
didn't offer the opinion that mr
floyd had an enlarged heart he offered
it from the stand
he didn't offer it in his report and uh
and had we known
at the time from the disclosures that
that's what he was going to testify to
then we would have addressed it during
his testimony during his
direct when he was here before uh well
let me let me ask you so what
specifically do you want
dr tobin to testify to regarding an
enlarged heart
uh he will simply testify that if you uh
then look at the uh the overall studies
including the the
the model study that we've been uh
talking about uh
that mr floyd's heart uh weight does not
fall within a range
uh that is abnormal um
so he'll talk about the uh the the
the broader sort of pool of studies in
in the framework of discussing the myo
study that that we had
uh learned about at least that
that that dr fowler was going to rely on
in his testimony i
i guess one question i have is
uh he's the pulmonologist he's not the
cardiologist are you recalling your
cardiologist to talk about the enlarged
chart and give an opinion about an
enlarged
no your honor just uh just the
pulmonologist and that obviously is a
cardiopulmonary system and and they
they both kind of operate kind of hand
hand and glove
so we we felt uh frankly in the interest
and respect and your honors admonition
that we try to be focused
uh substantively and temporarily to
simply call one person to talk about
this not multiple ones
okay what about the other on the issue
of the the hypoxia
uh for the first time uh from the stand
uh we heard uh from dr fowler
that uh ananoxic seizure
was evidence of a primary cardiac event
your honor
is is right and uh what your honor had
understood that both sides
do understand uh kind of what happens
when you have an hypoxia event and how
one passes away
what we had not heard was uh dr fowler
attributing it to a primary cardiac
event that was not in this report
and it was disclosed for the first time
from the stand
and as well as relates to the
hypopharynx uh that was crystal clear
from the stand
that dr fowler said having heard dr
tobin testify
i went out the canvas of literature and
i found nothing there supportive of
of of his theories for somebody who
uh has studied uh the science of
breathing for 46 years
so what doctor followed would testify
there is
what is the nature of the research
in that respect and direct response to
the uh
the new statement from from dr fowler
from the stand
uh let's talk about the opinion
regarding the carbon monoxide effect
and dr tobin's opinion which would
appear to be within the
scope of his expertise as a
pulmonologist but is it going to be
solely talking about
the lab tests it is solely talking about
um the carbon monoxide
content of his blood uh your honor and i
don't want to try to answer the court's
question
as clearly as i can so go ahead because
it isn't just talking about the test
results
uh the the test results uh are subsumed
in it
but but the bottom line and what he's
talking about is
uh what is the evidence as to whether or
not the carboxy hemoglobin content the
carbon
the carbon monoxide content of his blood
could have been in the range of
up to 15 and he's saying that best based
upon the medical evidence available that
was available to everybody
uh looking purely at the oxygen what was
available to everybody uh the oxygen
saturation
content of his blood okay and and uh
and contrary to council's uh comment on
the science
uh the way that the oxygen saturation
works
we have hemoglobin so either the oxygen
is going to combine
with the hemoglobin or carbon monoxide
will and if carbon monoxide has bound
to it then you can't have an oxygen
saturation of 98 i understood the
testimony
so so that is what he would speak to the
test results are merely corroborative
of that because the test results show a
specific testing for carbon monoxide
itself
and it is simply derived from looking at
the oxygen saturation content
which is at 98 and therefore the most
carbon monoxide could have been is two
percent
um so it is addressing the same issue
from the two different perspectives
oxygen saturation versus actual testing
in the test results of the carbon
monoxide itself
well i agree with you that if the tests
had been disclosed earlier before dr
fowler testified
there'd be no problem with putting that
in his rebuttal probably there
would have been no need because dr
fowler had been advised the results
and uh testified accordingly
so there would have been no need for
rebuttal so but other than that uh
so are those the four topics though did
council set those out
pretty clearly yes you're on all right
thank you all right
first of all in dealing with the these
lab test results
i find that the dr fowler's report gave
sufficient notice to the state that
carbon monoxide
the carbon monoxide that potentially was
in george floyd's blood
could have affected cause of death
i read
page 15 of his report which i don't have
at my fingertips at this point
that basically they said dr fowler came
right out and said it should be tested
that gave the state notice with
sufficient time in february to either
test
the samples that are still there or to
dig a little deeper
it's just by serendipity that
dr baker calls the state and says
oh by the way it does exist it should be
in there
it seems to me very odd i'm not claiming
any bad faith on the state's part
but it seems odd that hennepin county
medical center when they're asked to
turn
over all their records that they don't
include records that maybe are just
buried a little deeper
i think their uh response to the
subpoena is probably insufficient in and
of itself
they should check their standard
operating procedures so that in
the event this happens again that they
will supply all the information they
have
but in any case
the defense gave notice that this was
going to be an issue and specifically
talked about testing the sample
the state had sufficient time to
investigate and disclose
to even if it's just because dr baker
called the state and said
we we can actually find this at
eight o'clock this morning uh when the
state is
or the defense expert is done testifying
has left the state uh it's untimely
uh to give the notice and
it prejudiced the defense by the late
disclosure even if it's
not due to bad faith but the late
disclosure has prejudiced the defense
it's not going to be allowed so dr tobin
will not be allowed to testify as
those lab results if there's anything he
wished to add about carbon monoxide as
far as environmental factors
but if he even hints that there are test
results
the jury has not heard about it's going
to be a mistrial
pure and simple
this late disclosure is
not the way we should be operating here
in that case dr tobin may testify
as to carbon monoxide if he sticks to
the environmental factors and as a
pulmonologist
looking at the videos for example and
seeing mr floyd's location and
uh not knowing whether the vehicle is
even on or not which the state
brought out in cross-examination all
those factors he can talk about
environmentally
and what the likelihood is that it would
affect his carbon monoxide
concentration in mr floyd's blood that's
fine
but nothing about these lab test results
that were just just disclosed
8 am this morning after the defense
expert
is done with regard to the
demaio i will allow
i have a little concern that we're
having a pulmonologist opine whether
it's an enlarged heart or not
but given his background which as
i think mr blackwell appropriately said
it is a cardiopulmonary system it is a
system
and i think he has some expertise in uh
the function of the heart in its
relation
to the lungs and so i i think it is
appropriate that he'd be allowed to
opine whether or not
the heart was enlarged or not based on
those studies
and specifically responding to those
studies
as far as the scientific research the
defense did
bring up as a new issue whether or not
narrowing of the hype
both pharynx is supported in literature
and dr fowler said he did a check and he
didn't find anything
i think it is permissible that dr tobin
be allowed to come and say
since then since dr fowler's testimony
he has done his own search or
he relied on this and there is
literature and he can talk about
the literature in a summary fashion
with regard to the hypoxic seizure uh it
was pretty clear from dr tobin's
testimony that he had an opinion that
there were movements of george floyd's
legs that those were myoclonic
or anoxic seizures due to the lack of
oxygen
dr fowler did not really dispute that he
also indicated that it was a lack of
oxygen to the brain that causes such
seizures
the only difference between the two was
the mechanism
did the lack of oxygen was that caused
by
positional asphyxia versus cardiac
arrhythmia
and as i recall dr tobin excluded
cardiac arrhythmia or cardiac event as
the cause of the lack of oxygen since he
has excluded
cardiac a cardiac event as the cause of
the lack of oxygen
he's already that evidence is already in
the record
i don't have to remind both sides that
the purpose of rebuttal evidence is not
to restate what has already been
testified to
it's to bring up new evidence to rebut
something that came up
in the other side's case accordingly
as to the hypoxic seizure that's not
going to be allowed
the scientific research supporting
hypopharynx narrowing will be allowed
the lab tests uh are not allowed to be
discussed
but dr tobin can talk about
carbon monoxide and the likelihood of a
high carbon monoxide
uh reading based on environmental
factors a few wishes because that was
gone into a great extent
and finally the reports and he may opine
whether in his opinion
uh george floyd's heart was enlarged or
not
uh do we have the pretty much the ground
rule set
just one question for clarification uh
on the uh carbon monoxide
uh there were test results uh that
existed before the ones that are at
issue
from last night's last this morning what
dr
tobin these are ones that relate to the
oxygen saturation so
that was known before last night and
and so i haven't talked to dr tobin uh
this morning about
what he's going to say or when i might
ask the court for a few minutes before
we start
but uh what what he was able to come to
last night without seeing anything at
all related to these uh test results at
issue
was we had the results already both
sides do
on the oxygen saturation in his blood
from may 25th
2020. let me ask you this
is his opinion going to be that when the
oxygen saturation levels are
this high that precludes high co
because a high carbon monoxide reading
would depress the saturated oxygen
that's correct they are would be
inversely related so a high oxygen
saturation
would indicate a low carbon monoxide yes
mr nelson uh as i understood dr fowler's
testimony
the at lower levels of carbon monoxide
because the pulse oximeter does not it's
not going to differentiate based on the
color of the blood
between oxygen and carbon monoxide
this is the bright cherry red testimony
i think that's appropriate cross but i
think if that is in fact dr
uh tobin's opinion that these oxygen
saturation readings which have been
disclosed earlier
would indicate a low carbon monoxide
reading because they are inversely
proportional
or and it's appropriate however to say
those readings are based on pulse ox
color of the blood color of the
fingernail and
did you the bright cherry red
essentially
uh confronting him with that destiny i
think it's an appropriate cross but it
does not preclude
the state from recalling dr tobin for
that purpose yeah that's the
clarification you're on
all right thank you yeah that would be
permitted all right anything else before
and you want a few minutes to talk to
the to dr tobin uh why don't we start up
at 10 o'clock
i assume he's close by
you can do it quickly mr blackwell
i i think since the defense is going to
rest and and you'll proceed directly to
dr tobin are we calling anybody else
uh no no one else you're honoring if we
could have to 10 15
10 15 it is all right 10 15 will
reconvene thank you
all right good morning everyone sorry
for the delay
uh mr nelson
your honor at this time the defense russ
thank you mr blackwell does the state
have rebuttal
yes you're on you may proceed
good morning honor council ladies and
gentlemen
the state will recall to the stand dr
martin tobin
in just one moment not a problem
so
swear or affirm under penalty of perjury
that the testimony of vodka will be the
truth
and just for the record if you could
restate your name and if you feel
comfortable take
the mask off
my name is martin tobin
mr blackwell thank you robert uh good
morning dr tobin
mr blackwell uh thank you for rejoining
us
i've got just a few follow-up questions
not to ask you
uh in rebuttal uh but first just so
you're introduced to the jury
you're you're a pulmonologist correct
your lung specialist
yeah critical care physician yeah
intensive care doctor
and you studied the physiology of
breathing for 46 years
correct i want to first
ask you about uh the
issue of mr floyd's potential exposure
to carbon monoxide yes
uh were you able to hear testimony
regarding this yesterday yes i was
uh were you able to see
this particular um
slide and the highlighted uh statement
at the bottom of seven minutes missed
the floyd's
carboxyhemoglobin could have increased
by 10 to 18
percent correct yeah i saw that
uh
would you first just tell us right off
the bat do you agree
with that proposition that's highlighted
there no i do not
uh now would you tell us what
carboxyhemoglobin is
yeah carboxyhemiglobin is when the
carbon monoxide combines with the
protein in a blood
that's called the hemoglobin and so it's
the combination
of the carbon monoxide and that protein
in the blood and why is carboxy
hemoglobin
again important it's important because
when the carbon monoxide
binds to the hemoglobin it displaces
the oxygen off the hemoglobin so
you need the oxygen on the hemiglobin
you don't want the carboxy in it it
replace
it takes it over do you have an opinion
to a reasonable degree of medical
certainty as to whether this statement
that mr floyd's carboxy hemoglobin could
have increased by 10 to 18 percent
is reliable no i believe it is not
reliable
would you tell the ladies and gentlemen
why that statement is not reliable i
based it
on the arterial blood gas that was
obtained
when mr floyd was in henneman county
please cyber
i think the objection should be
sustained but uh just rephrase
thank you honor uh
dr tobin as uh you prepare to tell us
why these results
uh in your opinion are not reliable
could you please help the jury to
understand something about
oxygen saturation testing in the bond
right
so if you have like was done in mr floyd
when he went to henneman county uh he
had an arterial blood gas
obtained so that's sticking a needle
into the artery at the wrist
and you take out the blood and then on
the
blood gas measurements you measure a
number of different
items on that like the pressure of
oxygen in the blood the
pressure carbon dioxide the amount of
acid in the blood called the ph and you
get all these
different measurements and you also get
the oxygen
saturation and that is the
how much of the hemoglobin
the protein in the blood that carries
the oxygen how much of that hemoglobin
is saturated with oxygen
and we know in mr floyd that it was 98
saturated so 98 saturated with oxygen
with
oxygen when they measured it in henneman
county
and that was 9 16
the time frame so if we know that there
is an
oxygen saturation of 98 does that tell
us anything whatsoever
yes about what i'm sorry i interrupt i
apologize
does that tell us anything whatsoever
about what the carbon monoxide content
could have been at a maximum yes it does
it tells us
that if if the
hemoglobin is saturated at 98 it tells
you all there was for everything else is
2
and so the maximum amount of carbon
carbon monoxide would be two percent
it tells you the maximum amount of
carboxy hemoglobin
that was what was measured mentioned
yesterday the maximum amount is two
percent it doesn't even tell you that it
is two percent
it could be something else but two
percent of carboxy hemoglobin
is within the normal range you and i
have levels of carboxy hemoglobin of
somewhere between zero and three
and uh so in other words as to the
statement that his carboxy hemoglobin
could have increased by 10 to 18 percent
in your view that's not possible it's
simply wrong
and it was at most two percent at most
two percent
normal very i mean which is normal
uh new subject uh to discuss with you
you might recall if you're listening to
the testimony
uh my discussion with dr fowler the
hypopharynx
yes i remember and you might recall i
spent some time
asking him about what research he had
done
on the potential for pressure on the
back to narrow the hypopharynx
yeah i recall them uh do you recall him
saying he had canvassed the literature
and he could not find anything
i'm sorry uh do you recall him saying he
had uh reviewed uh the research and that
he could not find anything yes
i recall him saying that uh are you able
to
uh enlighten or give any information to
the jury on the nature of the research
on the hypopharynx and and how it
narrows
uh with uh compression in the prone
position yeah
so i mean the the research on this which
is
extensive is really in the scientific
literature it's in the physiological
literature
and then that is applied over to
clinical medicine
so the type of studies that are done are
not really done in terms of
ordinary clinical research it's much
more physiological much more scientific
of how the body works
and there's about probably at least a
dozen maybe 20 studies that show
the relationship between how that if you
lower
the size of the lungs you must
get a decrease in the size of the
hypopharynx
all of the studies show that
and then are there studies then that
look at whether the pressure on the neck
narrows the hypopharynx no
i mean because when we do research
we try and do research on studies
that might be puzzling that you would be
ex kind of expecting
a bit of a surprise if you think about
sticking your fingers into your
neck you know you're going to
narrow the hype of firings that's not
kind of research that somebody is going
to want to do
it's so common sense that you would know
that that's going to happen i mean you
can do it on yourself if you want
and as soon as you put pressure here you
can immediately
sense that your upper airway is
narrowing
dr tobin um that is all we wanted to
clarify with you this morning
[Music]
sure let's do a stretch break in place
there's the jury we're gonna actually
have a recess now until quarter two
so we'll reconvene at that time
still on the road dr tobin okay mr
nelson
just have a few follow-up questions for
you dr tobin thank you
um in terms of
the carbon monoxide testing that you
reference
you would agree with me that the most
common
technology available in hospital
laboratories for analyzing the blood is
the multiple wavelength
spectrum spectrophotometer also known as
the co-oximeter correct
right now in terms of your testimony
relevant to the research
the uh you reference that there were 12
to 20 studies
and if correct me if i'm wrong that an
increase in pressure on the lungs would
increase the narrowing
of the hypo pharynx not quite
okay can you just say it again yeah i
mean it is that if you decrease the size
of the
lungs that you will get narrowing of the
hypopharynx
and that research would be in
physiological journals
it would be in physiological journals
there are some journals that will be
a blend of physiology plus clinical
equity
but it's primarily going to be in
physiological
oriented journals and those
physiological oriented journals would be
included within the general search
for medical literature i mean if you go
into pubmed
it would be included in pubmed yes and
you have not produced any of those
12 to 20 articles for the state or i to
review
i mean i listed several articles in my
report of january the 27th there's
several
articles in that i can i can tell you
them if you want them
specifically that stand for that
proposition regarding the
relationship between lung volume and the
hypopharynx
i have no further questions know your
honor
all right thank you doctor you may step
down and you are excused
thank you very much
yeah mr blackwell
your honor the state of minnesota rest
mr nelson anything further members of
the jury the evidence is now complete
for this case
next step for you is to listen to
closing arguments and then retire for
deliberations that'll occur on monday
the attorneys and i will still be
working we have a few administrative
matters and legal matters to take care
of most importantly
going over the law that i will give you
in my instructions
and that takes quite a while and so we
are not going to change our
schedule we're not going to close
tomorrow we're going to close on monday
and so with that remember you will be
sequestered we have some of your
questions and we're going to try and
answer as many of those as we can
i think the one thing that you need to
know today as you leave is how much do i
pack
if i were you i would plan for long and
hope for short
basically it's up to the jury how long
you deliberate how long you need to come
to a unanimous decision on any account
and so because that's entirely up to you
whether it's an hour or a week it's
entirely within your province so that's
how i would do it if i were you
we'll also give you some information uh
probably monday as you retire as to
other questions that don't require your
immediate attention
and we will also be probably giving you
some hints as far as technology
we will be operating under the rules uh
that are currently in place regarding
audio and vid
video evidence and that is specifically
that you will be provided with
a laptop computer that has all the audio
and video
in fact pretty much all the exhibits in
this case on the computer
and with a large monitor to play them
you will not have to come back into the
courtroom each time you want to look at
the audio or video which is the old
rules
which involves a lot of back and forth
we're not going to do that
we're just going to give you that
computer with the arrangement so that
you can view it
as you deem appropriate as part of your
deliberations so with that
i wish you a good long weekend and we
will see you monday morning
let's we will convene at 9 00 a.m for
closing arguments and final instructions
thank you so much i'll rise for the jury
all right we are still on the record
outside the hearing of the jury uh with
regard to the charge conference i think
the parties had agreed that we could do
this informally off the record in
chambers is that correct from the state
yes okay mr chauvin
you have the right to be president at
all phases of the trial that actually
include the charge conference
but basically you'd be watching the
lawyers and i word smithing the
instructions and i think you already
have a copy
uh you want to be present for that are
you willing to waive your presence
all right uh we probably put any
discussions on the record
uh just to memorialize what we've
decided and you're willing for us to do
that without you president is that
correct
uh any requests that have already been
made by the attorneys as far as proposed
instructions
that constitutes a motion for me to give
those instructions to the jury so
there's no need for your lawyer to
object
to anything because if i don't give
anything your lawyer says
that's essentially denying the motion
for that proposed instruction the same
thing is true for the state any of their
proposed instructions
memorialize their request there is no
need for an additional motion objecting
to whatever i decide
is the final instructions with that
also we have all been talking about the
appropriate way to deal with
questions from the jury occasionally
jury questions will arise
i think our preference is that we not
move the jury around
if we can avoid it and also that we not
have people coming and going from the
government center
since you will not be required to stay
here at the government center while the
deliberation is occurring
accordingly our plan is that we do
any questions by zoom if you recall
earlier when i
brought back several of the jurors who
have been selected to talk about the
possible
effect that minneapolis city settlement
had
that's how we would do jury questions in
other words
they would be able to see us we would be
able to see them
and when i say we i mean the parties
yourself
uh but the jury because they are
anonymous would not be broadcast to the
outside world
and that would be our plan for how to
answer uh questions
any questions that come to me from the
jury the first step is to talk to all
the lawyers
get their input on what i how i should
answer it very often it is rereading
certain instructions but
in any case i will talk to all the
lawyers and after talking with them
formulate what my answer is going to be
that will be on the record but it will
be
by zoom are you fine with that
arrangement since you don't have to be
here
uh we would want you to be part of the
zoom so you've got to be subject to
getting in front of a computer basically
are you fine with that
all right uh anything else uh as far as
before we go into the charge conference
not from the states around
okay all right uh then we are
off the record until monday at
9am thank you
you